welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania does not end the way we
think it did it's spoilers before we
continue after re-watching this film
it's ending with Scott reflecting on his
supposed victory over Kang his momentary
paranoia followed by his switch back
into Bliss I discovered some new details
that I think we all missed before that
totally proved that the final minutes of
this film are all part of a simulation a
warped timeline or some kind of sakuran
nightmare scripted by the Kang Dynasty
and please subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive in which I will have a
deeper investigation of quantumania this
Friday February 24th and you can support
our growing Network by getting something
over at nerd riot.shop like this
quantumania inspired Quantum Thief shirt
or something from the deep dive
collection okay quantumania in swisscott
and hope escaping the quantum realm just
a bit too easily Cassie using her
Quantum communication device to locate
their spot and reopen a portal I mean
that was conveniently fast and
conveniently impossible almost like
someone let them get away but then Scott
Loops back in to the routine he started
this movie in with the same Welcome Back
Cotter theme song as if literally
nothing has changed in his life and like
that opening Montage we hear Scott's
voice over narration he says my life
doesn't make sense I used to ask myself
a lot of questions about that Scott you
just saved the quantum realm with your
family and drank a guy without holes why
does this kind of stuff keep happening
to you that doesn't make any sense but
you know what who said life has to make
sense now the weird thing about this is
that in the opening sequence Scott's
voiceover was revealed to be him reading
his Memoir look out for the little guy
in a bookstore who is he talking to now
it doesn't look like he's added an
addendum to his book or anything he's
just talking to himself or to us or
someone has scripted all of this as his
inner monologue and he's trying to
figure out what the hell he's saying and
there are some unusual ways Scott's
world has inexplicably changed the cafe
owner Reuben now knows who he is a bug
man who can grow big and Shrink small
and he charges 12 for coffee which
really throws off scott though you
shouldn't if you live in San Francisco
you're gonna overpay for coffee
everywhere at Baskin-Robbins God's
former boss Dale says he came out of K
retirement for him make it a green cake
with an ant decoration happy birthday
Cassie now I get why Dale is kissing up
to Scott he began this movie awarding
him the employee of the century but from
a public standpoint what changed in
Scott's life for Reuben to know who he
is suddenly would the public know what
happened to the quantum realm what
happens to the quantum realm stays
maguana realm cryolar can tell you that
now sure maybe Reuben suddenly
remembered organically that's got his
Ant-Man not Spider-Man but even Scott
senses something is often a sequence he
goes on saying it's been a pretty wild
ride one day you're fired from Baskin
Robbins the next you're beating a time
traveling space king we did beat him
right and then the Welcome Back Cotter
music Fades Scott says I mean that's
what happened he was gonna get out and
he didn't get out I think he also said
something bad was coming and that
everyone would die if he didn't get out
wait so did I just kill everyone is
everyone gonna die because of me why did
I what did I do you know what it's
probably fine like I said life doesn't
make any sense maybe stop asking so many
questions Scott stop overthinking it and
then we move on to Cassidy's birthday
dinner where Scott's in her monologue
continues to the end worrying this is
good we're all together you're fine
everything's probably fine King's gone
you did it never have to worry about
that guy anymore and they take the bite
of the cake and yuck but some visual
details we should talk about in other
videos already pointed out the new
graffiti of Ant-Man in a heart on the
wall but when was that drawn and why was
it suddenly drawn when it wasn't there
before a jogger runs past Scott
recognizing him Scott points back and
smiles and behind Scott you continue to
watch that guy he does a double take
looking back and forth from Scott to the
graffiti this is the kind of graffiti
that everywhere in the MCU following end
game you typically only see to honor
Avengers who died or disappeared Tony
Stark and Far From Home Captain
America's shield and no way home
Memorial's Division and others at
Adventures con and Ms Marvel but it's
almost like this Runner is shocked to
see Scott alive but all of these
pedestrians are acting really really
weird I am always on the go and I'm
always listening to music and podcasts
so I've always got to have a pair of
raycon everyday earbuds in
so raycon earbuds have quality stereo
sound enhancement with passive noise
isolation it's just you and your music I
can block out background noise like no
other so I can be out in the world but
still my own private audio cocoon the
touch controls make it easy to switch
tracks take a call or turn up the volume
tap and the music automatically pauses
when you remove your everyday earbuds
and it resumes with the tap when you
just place them back in your ears
whether you're looking for a pair of
everyday earbuds low latency gaming
headphones or a speaker with a battery
that will last all night at your next
party raycon has got you covered raycon
is premium audio at the perfect price
point so you can build great habits
without breaking the bank no wonder
raycons everyday earbuds have over 50
000 5 Star reviews if you're ready to
buy something small with a big impact
click the link in the description box or
go to buy raycon.com new rockstars to
get 15 off your raycon purchase like it
also talks about the vibrant colors you
see in this final scene Scott focusing
on a few people who wear a specific
shade of vibrant purple these colors
leap off the screen and contrast all the
green hedges in the frame and then
during the birthday dinner we see purple
balloons in a bright green cake purple
green the colors worn by Kang the
Conqueror Scott is seeing Kang
everywhere but really I think the colors
are meant to distract us from the
background extra so again are really
weird all of them are smiling waving at
Scott like the extras in The Truman Show
as if all of them are playing a part
like when Scott gets closer to that
bright purple best woman with the dog in
the carriage it feels like a horror show
at the end of this movie but one
undeniable glitch in this Matrix occurs
right when Scott begins to disassociate
what triggers that moment well notice he
looks in the direction of this woman
with a purple plaid top but it's not her
that freaks them out it's the couple
behind her why because this same couple
just passed Scott a second earlier they
were just behind him on the sidewalk and
now when he looks ahead of them he sees
doppelgangers of them approaching him he
is caught in a loop it's like the
simulation scene in The Matrix when
everyone Neo passes on the sidewalk are
twins and remember this is a Scott who
had just been stuck in a probability
storm where all he saw were variant
possibilities of himself now yes yes
this is somewhat common Gap in films and
TV shows where they have the same dozen
or so extras passing the actors on a
sidewalk again and again and those
extras will sometimes Jump Around in
frame as different tanks are cut
together this actually happened in
Multiverse Madness when the same extra
ran past Doctor Strange on the street as
strange was fighting gargantos but I
think the reason it's weird here and
worth talking about is that this scene
deliberately calls attention to the
extras it dresses them all in bright
colors and has them all smile and wave
at Scott interact with him the way the
scene is shot and edited wants us to
look at these people we're seeing this
all from Scott's point of view anybody
editing this scene would know if
background extras were jumping around
and so I believe Scott's fear has come
true in this moment I believe he has
returned not to the same timeline he
left but a new timeline that has been
warped and controlled by the Kang
Dynasty a dynasty that has been
Unleashed and militarized as a result of
the Exile being killed in this movie in
The Avengers getting that much closer to
multiversal incursions the dynasty has
now set Scott's timeline in which
everything seems to be going Scott's way
but is actually trapped him in a
narrative Loop like Truman on a Burbank
lot like the host of Westworld or like
the citizens of Westview being
controlled by Wanda Scott is in a
simulation so that when is lingering
paranoia begins to creep in he just says
no everything seems to be fine maybe
don't overthink it because Scotland God
bless him is one of the most trusting
and naive Marvel heroes we know and in
this reality we are about to learn how
people look like Jonathan Majors turned
up throughout history mayor of timely
Wisconsin Victor timely inspiration to
Howard Stark and a Stark family the CEO
of Kang Enterprises Mr Griffin who now
occupies Avengers Tower in Manhattan
every glitch every plot hole in the MCU
all possible evidence of the Kang
Dynasty's manipulation of the timeline
now that they are trying to keep the
Avengers from causing any further
multiversal incursions but you know what
folks kangs always leave trace's
Footprints their vanity reflected in the
colors of the world around us the
streets populated with NPCs prone to
glitching who just smile a bit too wide
in her monologues playing in our heads
with no practical audience that
contradict what we actually feel hey
another reminder to subscribe to the
Deep dive and watch one of the great
videos now live on the channel you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at EA
boss follow me rockstars And subscribe
to new Rockstar for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]